esta foto es la prueba de la
recuperación del líder de la oposición
rusa alexéi navalni por petición de la
familia fue trasladado a berlín en
estado de coma en un avión medicalizado
desde rusia donde logró sobrevivir a un
envenenamiento en el mensaje en avant y
expresa su alegría por haber podido
respirar por primera vez durante un día
entero sin ayuda de equipos médicos hola
soy naval team los extraño a todos
todavía no sé mucho de lo que pasa pero
ayer pude respirar todo el día por mi
cuenta en realidad por mi cuenta no use
ninguna ayuda externa ni siquiera la más
simple válvula en mi garganta es un
proceso asombroso subestimado por muchos
lo recomiendo la zona serie de análisis
los médicos alemanes llegaron a la
conclusión de que el opositor ruso fue
envenenado con la sustancia tóxica del
grupo noise ok los resultados fueron
confirmados posteriormente por
laboratorios en francia y suecia el caso
de naval ni ha provocado tensión entre
berlín y moscú en varias ocasiones
alemania le ha pedido al kremlin que
ayude a aclarar lo ocurrido en una
conversación telefónica el ministro de
relaciones
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov y su
homólogo alemán thomas que alemania deje
de politizar la situación en torno a
naval ni en un comunicado el ministerio
de relaciones exteriores ruso aseguró
que están listos para cooperar en la
investigación